SAMIR DUTTA: My
name is Samir Dutta.
I'm a junior studying
computer science
and minoring in economics.
And this past year I've been
working with the MIT Trade Lab
to apply machine learning
and data analysis
techniques in order
to try and figure out
trends in a database of
over 10 billion tariff rate
observations.
So a few interesting
things to consider
is you can see in
these six graphs here,
this is just for
six country pairs.
You can see a lot of
variation in tariff rates,
and our goal was to
try and introduce
economic and political factors
into a machine learning model
to try to predict changes
in these tariff rates.
Now, as you might expect,
economic and political
intuitions are qualitative.
And in order to get accurate
machine learning models,
you kind of need quantitative
continuous variables.
And so a large part
of this project
was to take economic variables,
such as negotiation power,
and quantify them into measures
that we can use in models.
So for example, a
few facts that we
found were very
correlated and important
were the democratic
level of a country,
whether or not it's
in a trade war,
and how the health
of the economy
is doing relative
to previous years.
And we were actually able to
use all these factors to develop
a model that had
over 80% accuracy
in predicting tariff rates.